The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today
we're going to talk
about partial
differential equations.
Let me just give a quick
review where we are.
So we're going to have
a PDE lecture today.
Then Professor Swan is going
to do a review on Friday.
There's no lecture on Monday,
but you have the quiz, too,
Monday night.
Wednesday, next week is
Veterans Day so it's a holiday.
There's no classes at MIT.
So the next time I'll
be lecturing to you
will be a week from Friday.
The homework following
the quiz will be posted
and so you guys can
get started on that.
That homework involves
a COMSOL problem
which, for those of you who
had trouble with COMSOL,
might take some extra
time, since it's
the first time you're doing it.
So I would suggest you at
least give it a try early.
I'm sure the TAs would
be very happy to help you
to force COMSOL to cooperate.
Bend COMSOL to your will.
All right, so we're going to
talk about partial differential
equations.
And, as it sounds,
what's different
about a partial
differential equation is,
it has partial
derivatives in it.
And so we have a lot
of equations like this.
So for example, I work
a lot on this equation.
It's a poor choice, isn't it?
OK, so this is the conservation
equation for a chemical species
in a reacting flow.
So the change in the mass
fraction of the species z,
at a point, xyz at time, t.
That differential is given by
a diffusion term, a convection
term, and a reaction term.
So this is a pretty
famous equation.
This is part of the
Navier-Stokes equations
for the whole reactive
flow system, which
I hope you guys
have seen already,
and for sure you will see,
if you haven't seen them yet.
And there's a lot of other
partial differential equations.
I work a lot, also, on
the Schrodinger equation.
That's another partial
differential equation.
And what's special about
the partial differential
equations is that, in this
case, this partial derivative
is respect to time, holding all
the spatial coordinates fixed.
And these partial
derivatives are respect
to space, holding time fixed.
A very important thing
about partial derivatives,
which you probably have
encountered in 1040 already,
is, it really depends
what you hold fixed.
And you get different
results if you
hold different things fixed.
Now the implication, when you
write an equation like this,
is that whatever
partials you see--
When I wrote this,
if I have this
and it has a term
that's like d squared,
dx squared, is one of
the terms in this thing.
This says t.
This says x.
The convention is, oh boy,
I better hold x fixed.
And here must be, I
must hold t fixed.
Because there's another
one in the same equation.
Now, you can change
coordinates however you want.
Just really watch out
that you carefully
follow the rules
about what you hold
fixed, when you change things.
Otherwise you can cause
all kinds of craziness.
Now you guys probably took
multivariable calculus
at some point in
your distant past.
And they told you very
carefully what the rules were.
So follow them.
And I suppose, when you're
doing thermo right now?
Have you started to do all
this partial derivative stuff?
Yeah, so you've seen
how completely confusing
it can be with negative signs
showing up all over the place.
And other things like this.
I don't know if you've
encountered this yet?
At least, I thought it was
confusing when I took it.
So just be aware.
It's the same thing.
Now, often you do want
to change the equations.
So you can write down
an equation like this.
But, for example, if you
have a special symmetry
of the problem, like it's
cylindrical, for example,
then you might want to change
the cylindrical coordinates.
And then you have
to just be careful
that you write that correct
Laplacian and cylindrical
coordinates.
Make sure it doesn't mess
up anything about what
you're holding fixed.
Sometimes you might want
to be crafty and use
some weirdo coordinates.
For example, if you wanted to
solve the Schrodinger equation
for h2 plus, it
turns out there's
a special coordinate
system called
the elliptic coordinate system.
And in that coordinate system,
the partial differential
equation is separable.
And so, if you do it in
that coordinate system,
you can actually solve
analytical solution,
which is pretty unusual for
the Schroedinger equation.
But it's a pretty
goofball coordinate system
and you really have to
watch out, when you convert,
to make sure you
do it just right.
But it's just the rules,
chain rule and the rules
about how to keep track of
what's being held constant.
And when you change,
will tell them, how,
being held constant,
how to change it.
Now in principle,
this problem is
like no different
than the ODE BBP
problems we were just doing.
You just have a few more terms.
And so, you can
use finite element.
You can use finite differences.
You can use basis set methods.
And it's really no different.
So all those methods
basically look the same.
You just get equations that
have more unknowns in them.
Because, for example, if you're
using finite element methods
or basis set methods
with a local basis set,
you need to put points both
in the x direction and the y
direction, and in this
case, the z direction,
and then maybe also
in the time direction.
So now you have a
lot of mesh points
in all different directions.
And so you get a
lot of mesh points.
And so fundamentally,
there's no problem,
but in practice,
there's a big problem
if the number of unknowns
gets to be so large.
That's the main problem.
So think about it.
You have some kind of
equation like this.
It's in three spatial
dimensions and in time.
How many points do
you think you need
to discretize your solution
in the spatial coordinate?
There might be somewhere,
might be 100, I don't know,
points might be enough.
And so now I have x and y and z.
So I'll need, well, just in
COMSOL, you saw this on Monday.
Suppose I just have
two dimensions.
Suppose I just have x and z.
And I start putting points in.
Well, I want to have some
points along this way.
And I want to have some
And so, I actually have an
unknown here and an unknown
here, and one there
and one there,
and one there and one there.
There's quite a few of them.
I think of how
many points I have.
Each of those is a point where
I have a little basis function.
And each one of those has a
magnitude of how much weight
I have on that basis
function, things
they called the d's before
in the basis functions.
And I have a lot of them.
Now, it's going to be, if
I have 100 points this way
and 100 points this way, I have
10,000 of these little points.
That means I have 10,000
unknowns I have to solve for.
10,000 unknowns are a lot harder
to solve for than 100 unknowns.
and if you saw, on some of the
problems we did with the ODE
BBP problems, even
with 100 unknowns,
we were having a lot
of trouble, sometimes,
to get the real solution.
All right?
So you can just see how
it just gets to be, like,
a big numerical problem.
So that's two dimensions.
The third dimension, you'll
get another 100 times
as many points.
You might have a
million unknowns.
And once you get up
to a million unknowns,
we're starting to talk
serious math, now.
OK?
Even for your good
computers that you have.
In addition, it's not just you
have the number of mesh points,
but it's the number
of mesh points
times the number of
variables at each mesh point.
So in the Navier-Stokes
equations, what variables
do you have?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Louder.
PROFESSOR: Velocity
and pressure, OK.
So you have pressure.
We have the different
components of velocity.
What else we got?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sorry, what?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, though, yeah.
Density or temperature.
Yeah, temperature maybe, so.
So maybe temperature would
be what you might use.
And then you'd have a state
function maybe with these guys.
What else would you have?
So then you'd have all
these species, right,?
The mesh fractions
are all the species.
So you have, like,
y, species one.
Mesh fraction, species two.
However many you got.
So that's a pretty
big set of variables
and you need to know all
these numbers at each point.
So this might be--
how many have we've got?
One, two, three, four, five,
plus however many species
we have?
So this is n species
plus 5 times the mesh.
And I told you the mesh
was what, a million?
So maybe I have 10
million unknowns.
So the issue, to a large
extent, has to do with just,
can I solve it?
Can I solve a system
of 10 million unknowns?
10 million equations,
10 million unknowns.
All right, so that's
going to be one big issue.
Now the other issues, we
still have the same problems
we had in ordinary
differential equations,
that we have to worry
about numerical stability.
We have to worry about
actually, is the whole problem
even stable to begin with?
Physically?
Because if it's not stable
physically, then probably
we're not going to
get a stable solution.
So you have all those
kinds of problems
that we had before
in the ODE case,
and now it's just sort
of amplified by the fact,
now we have boundary conditions
in more than one dimension.
So we have multiple
chances to screw it up.
And we're trying to figure
out how to set the boundary
conditions correctly.
And we have to worry
about stability in all
the different directions.
So those are the
different kinds of things
we have to worry about.
But it's all the same problems
you had before, just amplified.
Now, because of this problem
of the very large number
of unknowns,
currently, if you have
a problem that has
two dimensions,
you can kind of very
routinely solve it.
And things like
COMSOL on your laptop,
you can usually do those.
When you get up to
three dimensions,
you might be able to solve it or
might not be able to solve it.
And it could be, like, a
really big challenge sometimes
to solve it.
And then in reality, we have
problems like the Navier-Stokes
is four dimensions, right?
There's time, as well.
So then that gets
to be really hard.
And then the
Schrodinger equation
has three times the number of
electrons dimensions in it.
So that gets impossibly hard.
And so, specialized
methods are developed
to handle those systems with
a lot of dimensionality.
So, like, for the
Schrodinger equation,
people almost always do
it with basis set methods.
And there's been a huge
effort, over decades,
to figure out really
clever basis sets that
are really close to
the real solutions,
so that you don't need to use
too many basis functions to get
the good solution.
So that's the way to keep
the number of variables down.
In the Navier-Stokes
world, I'll show you
what people do to try
to deal with that.
There's many other problems.
I don't know all the
problems in the world.
But in general, when you
have three or more dimensions
in your PDE system, you're
looking up special tricks.
You're looking up, how
do people in this field
deal with this particular PDE?
Special ways that are
good for that kind of PDE.
All right, so I
said, one problem
was that you could have,
that the PDE system, itself,
can be intrinsically unstable.
So one example I know like
that is, detonation problems.
So if I have a system that
has some explosive in it,
or a mixture of hydrogen
and oxygen even,
and I have it in a
tube or something,
if I change my
initial conditions,
I can go from the case where
it's stable, that it just
sits there, a
hydrogen and oxygen.
Or it could turn into
a regular burning.
Or if I change the conditions
a little bit differently,
it could change into a
detonation, where it actually
sends a shockwave
down the tube faster
than the speed of sound,
totally different situation.
So those kind of
systems can be really
sensitive to the physical
initial conditions.
A very small spark can make
a really big difference
in a system like that.
And also, in your
numerical solution,
if the thing is
physically sensitive,
it'll typically be sensitive
also to numerical noise.
If you get numerical
noise at some point, that
might be enough to kick
it over from, say, not
igniting at all to
having a detonation,
which is a completely
different solution.
But another case,
like in biology,
if you're trying to study
the growth of a cell culture
or the growth of a
tumor, as you know,
if somebody has a tumor and
one of the cancer cells mutates
and does something
different, it can
have a really different
outcome of what
happens to the patient,
what happens to the tumor.
The whole morphology
can change completely.
Everything about it can change.
So that's the kind
of system, also, that
can be very sensitive
to small details.
A small change in one
cell, for example,
could be a really
big difference.
So this is not just
in combustion problems
you have these kinds
of instabilities.
All kinds of problems
have this kind of thing.
You can have just regular
chemical reactors,
like in multiple steady states,
little tiny fluctuations
can make it jump from one
steady state to another one.
That's another very
famous kind of problem.
There's another
class of PDEs where
it's stable in some sense,
but it causes a problem.
We call those hyperbolic.
And those are like
wave equations.
The solutions are
propagating waves.
So the equations of
acoustics, the equations
of electromagnetism,
are wave equations
where, basically, a wave
propagates more or less
without any damping.
So what happens, then, is you
have some numerical noise that
will make a little wavelet that
will propagate, more or less,
without any damping, too.
And it'll keep bouncing back
and forth inside your domain
numerically.
And if you keep introducing
numerical noise,
eventually the whole thing
is just full of noise.
And it doesn't
have much relation
to the real physical solution.
So hyperbolic systems of
differential equations
need special solution methods.
That in the numerical
method, it's
carefully trying to damp out
that kind of propagating wave
that's coming from the noise.
And they set them
up a special way.
I'm not going to talk about how
you solve them in this class,
but there's a special, whole
group of solution methods
that people use who are
solving acoustics equations
and solving
electromagnetic equations.
If you get into solving
shockwave equations--
I actually work for
Professor [? Besant. ?]
He has, like, electrochemical
shocks in some of his systems.
You have the same kind of thing.
You have to use special
mathematics to correctly handle
that, special numerical tricks.
But we're not going to get
into that in this class.
If you get into
those things, you
should take the PDE class
for hyperbolic equations
and they'll tell you just
all about the solvers
for those kinds of things
and special tricks.
And there's journal
papers all about it.
Here, what we're going
to focus primarily
on two kinds of problems:
elliptic problems
and parabolic problems.
And those problems
are ones where
there's some dissipation
that's very significant.
And so, in an
elliptic problem, you
introduce some numerical
noise and as you solve it,
the numerical noise
kind of goes away.
Sort of like intrinsically
stable all throughout.
Now the real definition
of these things,
parabolic, hyperbolic,
elliptic, has
to do with flow of information.
So in a hyperbolic
system, information--
there's regions of the domain
that you can make a change here
and it doesn't make any effect
on some domain part over there.
And so that causes--
because that
is the real situation,
that also propagates
into the numerical
solution method.
So for example, if I'm
modeling a shockwave that's
moving faster than
the speed of sound,
I can introduce any
pressure fluctuation
I want behind the
shockwave, and it
has no effect on the shockwave.
Because the pressure waves
from that pressure fluctuation
are traveling at
the speed of sound.
They won't catch
up to the shock.
So they will have no
effect whatsoever.
So if I was judging
what was happening
by looking at what's
happening in the shock,
I can introduce any kind of
random noise I want back over,
downstream of the
shock, I guess.
Yeah?
And it won't make any
difference at all.
And so, that's part
of the reason why I
need a special kind of solver.
If I have elliptic
equations, every point
affects every other point.
A famous case for that is,
like, this steady state heat
equation.
You have some temperature
source here, a heat source here,
and you have some
coolness source over here.
And there's some heat flowing
from the hot to the cold.
And the heat flow is
kind of slow enough
that everything sort of affects
everything else, since you
actually have, the heat
is trying to flow by,
sort of, every path.
And there's some insulation
that's resisting its flow.
And it has been in
the connectivity
of flow a certain way.
And those kinds of equations
are called elliptic.
And the methods that we
use for the relaxation mesh
that we showed are really good
for those kinds of methods,
for those kind of problems.
And then another kind of
problem that we get into a lot
is like this one.
This is called parabolic.
And typically, in the cases
we see that are parabolic,
we have time as
part of the problem.
Always what we
think should happen
is that what happens
in the future
depends on what happened in
the past, but not vice versa.
So you would expect
that when you're
computing what's happening
at the next time point,
it's going to depend on what
happened at earlier time
points.
But if you try to do it
the other way around,
it would be kind
of weird, right?
You wouldn't expect
that what in the future
really affected
stuff in the past.
So it naturally leads us to
sort of pose it as an ODE IVP,
or IVP kind of problem.
And we know initially,
some time zero something,
and we're trying
to calculate what
happens at some later time.
And so those kinds of
problems we call parabolic.
And the methods that we're
going to talk about mostly
are ones for solving parabolic
and elliptic problems.
And you can read, in
the middle of chapter 6,
has a nice discussion.
Just has the
mathematical definitions
of what these things are.
Now, even in a
steady state problem,
the problem can have a sort
of directionality to it.
So if you have a problem
that's very convective.
So you have a flow in a pipe.
And you have a nice, fast
velocity flow down the pipe.
What's happening downwind
is very much affected
by what happened upwind,
but not vice versa.
So maybe you're doing
some reaction upwind.
Say you're burning
some hydrogen.
You're going to get
water vapor made upwind
and it's going to flow downwind.
And you're going to
have steam downwind.
If I squirt a little
methane in downwind,
it doesn't actually do anything
to what happened upwind.
I still have a hydrogen
and oxygen flame up there
and it's been burning
and making steam.
Do you see what I mean?
So it has a directionality,
even though I
might do it as a steady state
problem and not have time in it
at all.
And you've probably already
done this, where you can
convert, like, a flow reactor.
You can write it, sort of, as a
time thing or as a space thing.
Time and space are so related
by the velocity of the flow.
We'll have similar kinds
of phenomenon then.
It's almost like a
parabolic time system
that, if the flow
is fast enough,
the fusion backup, anything
moving upstream is negligible.
It's all moving from
upstream to downstream.
And so then, you'll have
the same kind of issues.
In fact, you may
even try to solve it
by just starting it at the
upstream end and competing
stuff and then propagating what
that output from that first one
does to the next one
downstream, and then
do them, one at a time.
That would be one
possible way to try
to solve those kinds of problems
that are highly convective.
As you slow the velocity
down, then the diffusion
will start to fight the
velocity more and more.
If you make the
velocity very slow,
the Peclet number very
low, then you really
have to worry about things
diffusing back upstream.
And then it's a
different situation.
And that would be more like
the elliptic problems we have.
Because things downstream
would actually affect upstream,
if the flow is really small.
But typically for our
problems, the velocity
is always really high.
Peclet numbers are really
large and so not much goes
from downstream to upstream.
It's almost all
upstream to downstream.
This leads to a
famous situation.
If you look in the textbook
at figures 6.7, 6.8,
it's kind of a very
famous problem.
That if you just
do this problem.
So this is just an ODE problem.
So I just have convection
and diffusion, no reaction,
very simple.
This problem.
You'd think that I could just
use my finite differences,
where I would put, I could
use the center difference
for here and here and change
this into this obvious looking
thing.
You think that that would be a
reasonable thing to do, right?
And you can do
the same one here.
You can write--
I'm terrible with
minuses, sorry.
So these, the finite
difference formulas.
And so, you can write
these like this.
This stays equal to zero.
And now it's just an
algebraic problem to solve.
A system of equations,
you have equations
like this for every value of n.
And there's the mesh points.
You guys have done
this before, yes?
Yes.
OK, so famous problem
is, if you actually
try to solve it this way, unless
you make delta z really tiny,
you get crazy stuff.
So on figure 6.7,
they actually show
what happens for different
values of delta z, which
is different values of what they
call the local Peclet number.
So there's a thing called
local Peclet number, which is--
OK?
If you make the local Peclet
number too large, actually
anywhere bigger
than 2, and you try
to solve this
equation, what you get
is oscillations,
unphysical oscillations.
They'll make the
phi go negative.
It's crazy.
It looks like the simplest
equation in the world, right?
It's a linear equation, so
what's the problem with this?
But it doesn't work.
And so, then you could think,
well, why doesn't it work?
And there's, like, multiple
ways to explain this
about why this doesn't work.
I think that the best
way to think about it
is about the information flow.
So if the local Peclet
number is large,
that means that phi is
just flowing downwind
and diffusion is not doing much.
Because the Peclet
number is big.
And so, you really
shouldn't use this formula
to calculate the flow.
Because what happens downwind,
at point n plus one, I guess.
Here we have the flow this way.
So here's n minus one.
Here's my point n, n plus 1.
I really should not
include, is this right,
n plus 1 in this formula.
Hope I have those signs right.
I apologize if I
had them backwards.
Because I don't think
that what happens
downstream should really
affect this at all.
So really, I would do better
to change from this center
difference formula to what's
called the upwind difference
formula.
Where they would
say, OK, instead,
let's use phi of n minus, the
phi of n minus 1 over delta z.
Just use that instead
of using this formula.
Now, you wouldn't
think that that
would make much difference.
But it makes a
gigantic difference.
And so if you look at
figure 6.8 in the textbook,
you see you get perfectly stable
solutions when you do that.
But where you do
this one, you get
crazy, oscillatory,
unphysical solutions,
unless you choose
delta z really tiny.
Now, there's other
ways to look at this.
So I think this is the
correct way, the best
way to think about it is, it
has to do with information flow.
If you try to make your
solution depend on stuff
that it doesn't
really depend on.
So upwind does not really
depend on downwind.
If you force it to,
by choosing to include
that information here, you
end up with crazy stuff.
So that's one way to look at it.
Another way to look at
it is that, if you really
want to compute
these derivatives,
you've got to keep
delta z small.
Because we're taking
a differential.
We're turning it into
a finite difference.
And if you take your
delta z too big,
then it's a terrible
approximation to do this.
And you can look at it.
You can see that
what we're doing
is, when we have this problem
where the local Peclet
number is getting too large,
is we're actually choosing
delta z bigger
than the, sort of,
the thickness of the solution.
So if you look at the solution,
the analytical solution
of this problem, it's like this.
Where this has a very,
very thin layer at the end.
It's like the flow has pushed
all your stuff to one side.
And if you choose your delta
z to be from here to here,
that's how big your delta
z is, and then you're
computing the derivative of this
point halfway along from here
to where this is.
You compute your
derivative like that.
It's not a very good, not a very
accurate representation of what
the real derivative is here.
And in fact, you
really should have
a bunch of points here
and here and here and here
and here to really
resolve the sharp edge.
And so you did
something really crazy
to use a big value of
delta z to start with.
So that's another way
to look at this problem.
Now, the fix, by doing
this upwind differencing,
I think the best way to
look at this is saying,
well, I'm just going to
make sure I only depend,
I only make the equations
depend on what's upwind,
with the convective term.
Because there's nothing
convecting from downwind.
So just leave that out.
So that's a conceptual
way to think about it.
Another way to think about
it, which is in the text,
is that by doing this,
you're introducing
another thing called
numerical diffusion, where
you're actually, effectively
increasing the diffusivity.
Because this is a very
poor approximation
to the differential.
This is a asymmetrical
finite difference formula.
It's not a very good value
estimate of the derivative,
if delta z is big.
But you can write it out
carefully and write this out
and say, oh, this
actually is sort of
like this plus an
effective diffusivity
chosen very carefully, so the
terms cancel out just right.
And it turns out,
if you look at it
that way, the effective
diffusion you've
added, by using this
instead of that,
is just enough to make
the local Peclet number,
if you compute it with the
effects of this d effective,
to stay less than 2.
Which is what you need
as a condition to make
this numerically stable.
So I strongly suggest
you read that.
It's only two pages
long in the textbook.
It's very clear.
Just read, just look at it if
you haven't seen this before.
There's a similar thing and it
might be relevant to the COMSOL
problem that Kristyn showed
you on Monday, is you can--
In that case, there was a
region of the boundary here
that had some
concentration c naught,
and then there was, over here,
the concentration was zero.
The boundary is zero.
Here, it's some number,
17, whatever number it was.
And if you think of how
to model what's going on,
one way to look at it is, I
have a diffusive flux coming in
from the drug patch, diffusing
the drug into the flow.
And I have this big, giant
flow, flowing along here.
And the flow gets slower as I
get closer to the wall because
of the friction with the wall.
And so if I looked
somewhere right in here,
I could just draw a
little control volume,
and look what's happening.
I have a diffusive
flux coming in here.
I don't have any drug
up here, so there's
no drug coming in here.
But I have drug leaving.
So basically, it's coming up and
it's making a right-hand turn.
And so then I could
think, well, if I
was going to try to
figure out, what's
the steady state concentration
of drug in there, I could say,
well, there's a
certain amount of drug
entering from the
diffusive flux, which
would be just this times dcdy.
This is the y direction.
And then this part
over here would
be the velocity, actually,
just times the concentration
I have in here, right?
So how much is flowing out.
And it's probably, my units
are screwed up so there's--
Well, maybe not.
That's OK.
Is that all right?
Units are screwed up.
You guys will get it right.
It's probably an area.
Something to do with
this size right here.
This one here, too.
Is that right?
So you could compute
what the steady state
concentration would be if it's
just coming in and flowing out.
And so, this is the
finite volume view
of this kind of problem.
And so you can write the
equations that way, instead.
And what you really care about
are what the velocity flows
and the diffusive fluxes
are on these boundaries
around the point.
So you don't try to compute
things right at the point.
You compute around it.
And one way to look
at this is, we just
did finite differencing.
We were looking at what
was happening coming in.
And then, this is actually
a center difference
around this interface, which is
halfway between the two points.
And so actually, this
is a good approximation
for the finite
volume point of view.
This is all right?
Now, these are
all different ways
to write down the equations.
All of them are
correct in the limit
that delta z goes to zero.
If you have an infinite
number of mesh points,
all these are exactly the same.
But they lead to really
different numerical properties
when delta z is large.
And they're all inaccurate
when delta z is large,
so it's all about what
happens with the inaccuracies.
Now, we can go ahead and
take any problem, even
really complicated 3-D problems
or 4-D problems like this,
and we can write them
with relaxation methods.
And what we're basically
doing in a problem
like this is turning it
into some function of y
is equal to zero, where y is
the value of all the unknowns.
And there's a lot of equations.
So I might have 100
million equations
and 100 million unknowns
that are the values,
or every state variable at
every state point at all times.
And I can write it down,
by finding differences,
by finding elements,
by finding volumes.
Any way I want, I can write
down an expression like this.
And I know in the
limit, as I make
the number of elements
of y go to infinity,
it will actually be
the real solution.
And the problem is, my
computer can't handle
infinite number of unknowns.
In fact, it's even
going to have trouble
with a 100 million unknowns.
And so, I have to
figure out what to do.
So how would I
solve this normally,
is I would take the Jacobian
of this and I would do,
I'd take an initial guess
and I'd update it and have
the Jacobian times my change
from the initial guess
to the equal
negative of f, right?
You guys have done
this a million times.
As Newton-Raphson
is how you'd find
improved from an initial guess.
You have to provide
some initial guess.
This is actually pretty hard if
you have 100 million unknowns.
You have to provide the value of
the initial guess for every one
of the 100 million.
But somehow you did it.
And now you want to refine
that guess and this is
the formula for it.
And so, you just use
backslash, right?
But the problem here is that now
f is a 100 million long vector
and this is a 100
million squared matrix.
And a 100 million
squared is pretty big,
10 to 16th elements in it.
So I'm not going to
just write that matrix
down directly like this.
Now, we cleverly chose
local basis functions,
so this is going to be
sparse, this Jacobian.
So most of the numbers, are
those 10 to the 16th numbers
in this matrix are zero.
So we don't have
to represent them.
But there still
might be quite a few.
Probably the diagonal
events are non-zero,
so that's like 10 to the
8th of them right there.
And we've got, probably,
a couple of other bands.
So I don't know, might be 10
to the 9th non-zero elements
inside this thing,
which is pretty nutty.
And depending on how much memory
they provided in the laptop
they gave you, you might
be filling up the memory
already just to write down j.
And certainly, if you tried
to do Gaussian elimination
to solve this, you're going
to have a problem because you
get what's called fill in.
Do you guys remember this?
Even if you start from
a very sparse Jacobian,
as you run the Gaussian
elimination steps
the number of non-zero entries
in the intermediate matrices
gets larger and larger.
Remember this?
And so, even if, initially, you
can write down j and store it
in your computer,
you could easily
overwhelm it with the third
iteration or something.
So you're not going to just
use Gaussian elimination.
So what do you have to do?
You want to find a method.
They're called direct.
Direct methods to solve
this kind of problem,
in order to get your
increment, which
is going to be your update, to
get a better estimate of what
the solution is.
And the direct methods are
ones that you don't actually
store the gigantic matrix.
So you're trading off
CPU time for memory.
So you don't have enough memory
to store the whole thing.
Which we, normally you would do
this with Gaussian elimination
and huge steps.
It would solve it
perfectly, right?
Right, Gaussian elimination's
great, backslash.
You guys have used
it a few times.
It's a really nice program.
It always works.
It's really nice.
But you're going to give up
that because you can't afford it
because the memory, it's
consuming too much memory
and your cheapo department
didn't buy enough
RAM in your computer for you.
So you're going to instead
try a direct method which
is, so it's trading off
CPU time versus RAM.
So you're going to reduce
how much memory you actually
actively have, but you're
going to expect that it's
going to cost more CPU time.
Because otherwise, everybody
would do something else besides
Gaussian elimination all
the time, and they don't.
All right, so what's the
method we're going to use?
It turns out that variance on
the conjugate gradient method
turned out really well.
So we mentioned this
earlier, briefly.
What you do is, instead
of trying to solve this,
you try to solve this.
So you just try to
minimize that, right?
You know at the solution
this is going to be zero.
Right, jy plus [INAUDIBLE]
zero when this is solved.
So you try and vary
and find the delta y
that makes this go to
zero by minimizing it.
And then this
method, it turns out
that the conjugate gradient,
if everything works great,
this is guaranteed
in n iterations
to go directly to the solution
of this kind of problem.
Now n is large, now, because
we have 10 to the 8th unknowns.
So that's 10 to
the 8th iterations.
You do anything in 10
to the 8th iterations,
you're not really sure
it's really going to work.
So that's a warning.
But at least it should get,
even after a few iterations,
you should get a smaller value
of this than you had before.
And so this is the method.
And what's really nice
about this method,
if you look into the
details of how it works,
it never has to store any
intermediate matrices.
So all it needs
is the capability
to multiply your matrix
times some vector.
And from that multiplication,
it figures out a step direction.
That's the trick of this method.
And because it only has to
do a forward multiplication,
you don't have to
actually store j.
You can just compute elements
of j, as needed, in order
to evaluate this top product.
This j times v. And you
don't have to ever store
the whole j at once.
So it's really great for
RAM to do this method.
Now, as I said, when you do
10 to the 8th iterations,
things don't always
work out so well.
And so people have found that
when you go more than maybe
10 or 20 iterations
like this, you tend
to pick up numerical problems.
And so, they've worked
out better methods.
And there's one that people
use a lot for these problems
called bi cg stab.
Which is biconjugate
gradient stabilized.
The applied mathematicians
went crazy trying to figure out
better methods like this.
And this is the one
that, I think currently,
people think is the best.
Though probably, there's
a lot of research on this,
so maybe there's
even better ones now.
But inside Matlab, I think
this is the best on they have.
And this is a method
for doing this.
Now, it's iterative.
Now, let's remember
what we're doing.
We're trying to
solve this problem.
We started with a guess.
We're going to break it up into
an iterative problem like this,
where we're going to
do some steps, delta y.
This is now doing
iterative procedure
in order to compute delta y.
So we have an interim procedure
and another iterative procedure
inside the first
iterative procedure.
So this is going to be
a lot more CPU time.
So just to warn you.
And it's also,
it's not guaranteed
like Gaussian elimination,
to beautifully come
to machine precision solution.
It's going to get you something.
But anyway, this
is what people do.
So that's one good thing to try.
Now, this whole approach is
sort of based on Newton-Raphson.
We know that doesn't have the
greatest radius of convergence.
So you need to provide a
pretty darn good initial guess.
So how are we going to get
a good initial guess if you
have a 100 million unknowns?
So what methods do we know?
So one idea is you
could do things
like homotopy, stuff like that.
If you could somehow
take your PDE system,
get rid of the nonlinear terms.
You're really good at solving
linear systems of PDEs.
You start with that
and then you gradually
turn the non-linear term on.
Maybe you could coax it over.
So that's one possibility, if
you're really good at PDEs.
Another possibility
that I've run
into a lot is the problem you're
trying to solve, for example,
might be a steady state
problem like this.
Where this is zero and
you try to figure out what
the steady state situation is
in a flow reactor, for example.
And so, it's actually,
your steady state problem
came from a time
dependent problem.
And if you think that your
time dependent problem really
converges to the
steady state problem,
sort of without much
concern about what
the initial guess
is, then you could
put any random initial
guess in and march it along
in time enough, and
eventually, it should end up
at the solution you want.
So that's the idea.
So that's called a
time marching idea.
So there's one idea, sort
of the homotopy continuation
kind of idea.
That's one idea about what
to do for initial guesses.
Another idea is the
time marching idea.
And the key about it is,
you have to really believe
that, physically,
the system does march
to the steady state you want.
If it does, then
this is a good idea.
If it doesn't, then you're not
going to end up where you want,
because it's not
going where you want.
And so, you have to watch out.
But in some situations, this
is true, that things work.
So I do a lot of
combustion problems.
A lot of these things, you
light a spark on a stove burner.
No matter how you
light it, it ends up
basically the same flame.
So that's a good one.
But I have some other ones
where I light a candle
and I'm in a convective
field, a turbulent field,
and it flickers.
And no matter what,
it always flickers.
And I never get a steady
state, so I'm never
going to find a steady state
solution with that one.
And so I could time
march until I retire.
My computer's still burning
CPU time all that time
and it'll never get to
a steady state solution.
So you really have to know
what the real situation is.
But if you have one where
it's going to converge,
then this is a reasonable idea.
Now let's talk about
the time marching.
The time marching,
you have, say, dy,
dt is equal to some
f of y where this
is the discretized
spatial vergence.
I took all the space
dimensions and replaced them
with the finite
difference expressions
for the derivatives.
Or I did colocation or
something to convert this
into algebraic equations.
So the right-hand side is
now algebraic equations, no
longer differentials.
And now, I'm going to time
march this and I just--
This is very long.
It's a 100 million.
So how are we going
to time march that?
Well there's kind of two
schools of thought for this.
One school of thought is, if
I can use an explicit method,
an explicit ODE solver,
those are pretty nice.
Because all I have to do
is evaluate f and then
I can march along and I never
have to save any matrices.
Because remember, look
at those formulas, y,
y new, by the
explicit method, is
equal to some
function g of y old.
And this is the update formula.
It can be forward Euler.
It could be RK 2.
It could be whatever.
But there's just some
explicit formula.
I plug in the old vector.
I compute a new vector.
I never had to do any inversions
of matrices or anything.
So that's good.
And this is, indeed, the
way that the Navier-Stokes
equations are solved currently
by the best possible solver.
So the best solver in the
world discretizes in space
and then does ODE IVP
using explicit method
for marching it.
They do problems
that are pretty big.
So they'll have like 100
million mesh points and then 100
species.
So they have 10 to
the 10th unknowns.
And at each time step, you're
computing another vector
that's 10 to the 10th long.
So it's a pretty big problem.
And they use, like, 40% of one
of the national supercomputer
centers will be running at one
time for one job like this.
But it works.
You never have to store
anything that's too big.
The biggest thing you have
to store are the vectors.
Which, you're
always going to have
to store some object the
size of your solution,
right, if you're going
to get your solution.
So that's one possibility.
Now, this is really good if an
explicit solver can solve it.
So that means it's just
not stiff, your problem.
And also, if you want a
time accurate solution.
So in that case, they actually
want the time accurate
solution.
But suppose we're trying to
really solve the steady state
problem over here.
Then we really don't care
about the time accuracy.
We're not going to report
anything about our time steps.
In the end, we're only going
to report our steady state
solution.
That's all we cared about.
So in that case,
there's no reason
to try to have a really high
accuracy, explicit formula
and try to make sure we all our
time steps are exactly right.
We're just going to throw away
all those time points anyway.
We'll just keep the final
one as our initial guess
for a Newton-Raphson solve
to find the steady state.
So in those cases, you
might instead want to use--
So this is time accurate.
There's another method.
I don't know if I should
call it time inaccurate.
If you don't care, if
the solution is really,
what the solution
yft is, all you
care about is where you get to,
then you can do other methods.
And one of them is
the backward Euler.
So you can say, well,
y new is equal to y old
plus delta t times f of y new.
Now, the advantage of this is,
I can make delta t pretty large.
This is guaranteed
stable as long
as the ODE system is stable.
Remember?
And so, this will go to this,
go to the solution pretty well,
to the steady state solution.
It won't go there in
the right amount of time
because this is a very
low order of formula.
It's not really accurate.
But it will end up to the
real steady state solution.
This is what's
actually used a lot.
However, the problem
with this is, this is now
an implicit equation.
So we may have to solve
it with some method
like Newton-Raphson.
But we got into this
because we couldn't
solve our Newton-Raphson
steps because we didn't
have a good initial guess.
So then the question is, can
we find a good initial guess
for this problem?
And in this case,
you can because you
can use the explicit formulas to
again provide the initial guess
for this implicit formula.
So that's what they do, also.
And so now, if we're doing an
iterative procedure in order
to get the initial guess for
our other iterative procedure
ever there, which
we're going to break up
into another iterative procedure
inside it to solve every step.
But this is currently
what people do.
So you guys are smart.
Maybe you can figure
a better way to do it.
The world is waiting.
I think I'll stop there.
By the way, actually
just names--
This kind of thing is
called method of lines.
And if so, if anybody ever
says I solved something
by method of lines,
what they meant was,
they discretized in
some of the coordinates
and they kept one of the
coordinates as a differential.
And then they solved it with
an ODE solver at the end.
And in certain systems like
this, it's a smart thing to do.
You need to be kind of lucky
that the set up is right,
so you can use it.
But if you can, it
can be pretty good.
All right.
See you on Friday.